[Music]
all right let's go to elizabeth in
columbia south carolina what's up
elizabeth how are you doing
hi dr john it's so great to talk to you
it is super great to talk to you what's
up
all right so topic of my question is on
gun ownership
oh cool we're just gonna come out uh
we're gonna come out uh we're gonna slow
roll this one out of the gate way to go
all right let's talk guns right to the
point let's talk about it okay so gun
ownership and how to approach the topic
of bringing guns into the house with my
roommates okay need some backstory back
it up
okay so context so i i rent a house with
three other girls you know we're great
friends we've known each other for a
while part of the same church community
were great together and recently i found
out that one of them
actually is real has a history of having
guns is like a hobby like her family's
really into it and when i found out that
i was really excited because i've been
wanting to learn about how to shoot for
a while now okay and so when we both
found out that we were interested we got
really excited we talked about
potentially you know buying our own guns
in the future and going and her teaching
me how to shoot and that's going to the
range and just having a good time like
that
the issue that we've come across is we
don't know how to approach
that topic with our other two roommates
like whether or not we need to even
disclose that we're getting guns at all
if we don't even plan on giving them any
access to them
or if we need to have like a roommate
meeting prior or i just wanted to get
your
opinion on that and think about if
there's any other factors i'm not taking
into consideration
so i got so many questions this is
fantastic okay
um
trying to think of how to start
so let me frame it this way and this is
me talking to you this is me also
talking to the audience just to give
them some context um i'm the son of a
homicide detective
who's born and raised in texas
and
i had a great one of my therapy
professors my counseling professor she
dr marbley says
gave me some wisdom that was so great
she said she's from chicago and then
she's a professor in texas and she said
problem with talking about guns is we
talk past each other
because in texas
and i'm using texas in south carolina
and wherever right alabama whatever you
want to say um
regionally
a grandmother will have a small gun in
her purse
it's just kind of like i don't i i don't
know anybody in my life i do now but at
the time i didn't know anybody in my
life that didn't have a shotgun
it's just a way of being
and then in
she said in chicago i didn't know
anybody
that had guns that wasn't some involved
in some sort of crime right and and of
course this is 15 years ago the 10 years
ago has change but she said so when
somebody in one part of the country
hears about guns they instantly have a
picture of a bad person in the other
part of country when somebody mentions
guns they instead have a picture of
their grandma
and so we end up with different pictures
we use the same words we're talking
about guns and gun ownership and what we
do and we talk past each other
and so i've been around guns my whole
life i have a bunch right not a bunch
like i'm not an arsenal guy but i
i i that's that's and and
i've cleaned brains off of a bathroom
wall before
and i have
hugged mothers and i have been after
shootings and i've been uh
i've helped be a part of swat training
exercises so there is a stark reality to
the other side of this thing okay and i
think both sides of the conversation get
awesome so grateful that you're asking
this question because i think there's a
a different way to have this
conversation than we've been having um
so
let me ask you
i got two questions one's gonna fully
answer your question the other one is
kind of a diversion here first question
is
there's something about your other two
roommates that you know they won't like
this or you wouldn't even be asking me
this question so what is that what's the
what's your concern with bringing it up
okay so
with one of the two
i'm like 99 sure she'll be fine with it
because like
she's just a level-headed person in
general
she's even disclosed that she has a like
a stun gun that she keeps on her in her
room just for like safety reasons okay
the other one
she
she actually has um
i know it used to be called asperger's i
know they don't really use that term
anymore yet but basically high
functioning autism okay
and we've had some issues in the past
with just her getting like overly
emotionally stimulated about certain
things like coming on in the house and
we just had some issues with that so we
aren't really sure how she would
react to even the thought of there being
a gun in the same house where she she is
okay so i want to um i don't think if
somebody chooses for them and their
household that they don't want to have a
gun in there that doesn't mean they're
not level-headed i think i think that's
fine right um i think it's a super
personal choice
um i think hysteria on either side of
the conversation um is where you get
into the level-headed conversation but
if someone chooses like
i'm just not for me i don't i don't want
that in my home i don't want the risk
the risk statistically is infinitely
more likely that you're going to hurt
yourself with your own weapon than
you're going to actually like pew pew a
bad guy that's just reality
and
um
there's also some data out there that
suggests that when people are armed in a
community the crime goes down because
everybody knows like i'm just gonna mess
around so it's both and we need to keep
having this conversation
um
so let me back out one step further why
do you
want one
do you want to go i've got some buddies
that um
they don't play golf they shoot trap
they go to the range they shoot skeet
they have these fancy shotguns and
that's just what they do that's just
their thing or they are distant shooters
they're scope shooters and they
like will sit there all day and they
dial in these things and they got these
cards for elevation and wind and they do
all this stuff
um and they like to they like to shoot
there's something about the power of it
all and the the the concentration and
the focus all the stuff it just becomes
like a thing right like a hobby
they have to reload their own bullets on
it and then there's other friends of
mine who are former military or police
officers or people that just are have
guns they're around guns they know how
to use them and they are more bent
towards personal defense and if
something goes down i want to make sure
we're good and then i've got my other
friends
that watch way way way too much john
wick
way too much and they watch way too much
news and they're like if it goes down
i'm gonna get on my horse and get a
sword and have my
red dot ready to
and they're insane they're my friends
but they're bonkers right so why do you
think that you want to have it is it
something fun is it exciting or is it a
self-defense thing or is it a fantasy
thing what is it
mainly i just i'm interested in like the
sport of it like the the first example
you gave just like going to the range
thing you know
you're shooting that focus on
concentration i've always been
interested in that not so much like
self-defense or just like crazy john
wick fantasy
okay so what i would recommend here and
and this may be a controversial
statement whatever i don't care
i think every single human being should
have some sort of training on how to
handle a weapon even if it's to simply
unload one
really quickly and it takes one and a
half i mean it takes less than a half
second to unload a gun to how how they
work i think that's important how to
handle one if you ever had to pull the
trigger it's very very different if
you've never done it than you than it
looks like on tv
and i so i i actually think that's wise
i think that's good
i think there's some steps between
going to buy a really expensive fancy
gun and all guns are expensive these
days
versus hey we're gonna start going to
the range and you can rent a range gun
when you're there and they'll teach you
how to work it or you can take classes
where they'll let you use weapons when
you're there i think there's some steps
in between
the bigger question is
let's take guns off and these are like
when i get questions about um you know
transgender issues or abortion issues or
gonna i wanna take the issue off the
table for a second and just come back to
you have a value or a belief or a desire
or a need one of those four things
and you are
feeling uncomfortable living in your own
home
so the conversation is less about guns
right now and it's more about
as you described it i've got a roommate
who gets overly emotional about certain
things and i'm increasingly
uncomfortable because i can't even bring
up this i can't even have it approach a
conversation and when i find myself in
my home and i can't even have a
conversation about it then what i have
i've got secrets and secrets turn to
resentment and you hear me say that all
the time resentment turns to ash and
then the whole thing becomes a mess and
then it's not about guns at all gun
become the proxy war for i don't like
you i don't want to live with you
because i can't quote unquote be myself
i can't tell the truth in my own house
am i onto something there
yeah what's there's another there's
probably something else besides guns
that you don't want to talk to her about
what is it just pick one there's
probably several
i mean it's
living with someone who
has like that high functioning autism
it's taught me a lot about how to
put the needs of others above my own i'm
really grateful for that because it's
taught me how to be a lot more humble
person yeah like there are certain
arrangements in the house we've had
there are certain arrangements in the
house we have to make like she
like can we have to park our cars in a
certain place in the drive-through
because she
has a certain preference for where her
car gets parked and her the kitchen has
to be arranged a certain way and
i have no problem with that it's just
it's gotten a bit
much at certain times that i've had to
go through that with her so what i would
i don't want a couple of things
you can honor her as your friend
and as a
woman with autism
and you can say i'm gonna choose to not
live here all of that can be true at the
same time
okay
and
the
i what i don't want you to do is i don't
want to blow your house up over the gun
issue because i don't think guns are the
issue it's not if you guys want to go
shooting i think that's fantastic i
think everybody should go take a class i
i fully believe that
um
and
i'm also a safety zealot when it comes
to guns in my own house i'm a lunatic
about the safety of it right so i think
it's all both hand
i think the real challenge here is
you've got a roommate that um you all
are starting to
get tense with and i don't want the
quote-unquote gun issue to be the thing
that breaks you up i'd rather
here's my needs now my needs are when i
get home from work that i thought of oh
god i parked the car in the wrong
direction in the wrong space i i want to
choose to not live like that and so guys
in four or five months i'm gonna start
slowly looking for it's a new place for
me and for or for me and roommate x and
that'd be great for us it's gonna be
great for y'all we're still friends all
that i'm gonna start i'm gonna start
leaning that way this is a conversation
half and rents are
crazy expensive so you may have to find
other roommates that's fine or you can
sit down and to your with your autistic
um roommate and say hey
these are really important things to you
these are really important things to me
and we have to come to some sort of
consensus because we're living together
and what i'll tell you is i've
i've worked with
innumerable high functioning autistic
folks that hear that and get that and
i've seen some extraordinary steps
people have taken to
say okay i don't understand what you're
feeling
i can't process what you're feeling but
i trust that you're telling me the truth
and so i'm going to act differently i'm
going to go see my cars parked in the
wrong spot and i'm going to feel it all
over my body and then i'm going to
choose to
you see what i'm saying so
it's it's putting your needs above other
people's important and also speaking
your needs out um and letting being
heard explicitly is important too
see what i'm saying
yeah
so what are you gonna do
i might talk this over with the other
roommate who's interested and
we can see about whether or not
we need to arrange a meeting with the
other two and just
see what their thoughts are i have been
in some rooms with folks um with autism
that when
they felt ganged up on
the alarms got real real loud is there a
way you could go have coffee with with
your roommate
yeah
mm-hmm and say how are you feeling
one-on-one yeah that would that would be
better
is that similar to your situation that
when everybody kind of starts saying
yeah and yeah that all of a sudden man
then
your your your autistic roommate gets
real defensive
oh yeah definitely yeah i think a more
humane approach might be just 101 tell
me how what you're thinking about tell
me how you've seen our relationship over
the last um and the beauty of of not all
but but some highly functioning autistic
folks is
um they're incredibly logical and
analytical it's wonderful
because we can really like you have your
needs and i have mine and they are
starting to butt up against each other
are there places where we can compromise
together i think that's a incredible
next step
um and if you think of it this way
you'll be giving your roommate a gift
too
you'll be giving yourself a huge gift
which is finally letting your needs be
spoken
before there's a fight because when you
have a fight they're gonna explode and
it's gonna be like you stupid liberal
and you dumb conservative now we're not
even fighting about that
the sadness is i i have to hide in my
own house and you don't want to do that
anymore and that's totally respectable
and yes go to the range go take a class
and that'd be important think they'd be
a lot of fun and make sure you get a
good coach and make sure y'all really
safe
and don't watch too much john wick it's
just
if you have a sword and a horse for sure
you need to take out some guys on
motorcycles other than that let's just
back off the john wick